Brian Richards, your friend,
a wildlife biologist and um,
well we're going to talk
about a bunch of things,
but one of the things that I wanted to
talk about is this scary disease that uh,
well when Ted Nugent was on the podcast,
he downplayed the consequences and
effects of something called CWD or chronic
wasting disease,
which has made it onto your farm and
you live in Wisconsin and you have this
beautiful place that we visited when we
did the immediate or television show.
And, um, this is a new thing that this
chronic wasting disease was just, it just,
it decimates the deer's
health and kills them.
And the suspicion is that some of this
at least comes from these high fence
operations where people grow
dear, um, and treat them like,
instead of like a wild animal,
they treat them like a domesticated animal
and have them all feeding off of the
same pile of food and
they share this disease.
Is this all correct and accurate?
Brian?
Boy, you just started out about
an hour's worth of congress.
Um, so yeah, just a little bit. I'm a,
I'm allowed to let biologist with
the national wildlife health center,
US geological survey up in
Madison, Wisconsin. And so, uh,
one of the things that I spend a lot
of time on is chronic wasting disease.
I wouldn't say that makes
me necessarily an expert,
but I've gotten to know a lot of people
that I would call experts over the years.
So I've gained a little bit of outage.
So I don't even mean your,
your statement there. We could
start a number of different places
this disease.
Um,
essentially just describe what it does
do these animals and why it's such a
major concern. It hasn't jumped
to humans yet that we're aware of,
that we're aware of, but it is a
possibility, a very real possibility.
We can't rule it out at this
point in time. Science is
unable to rule it out. So,
okay,
that's a great place to start.
Why would we care about this thing
called chronic wasting disease?
And I would argue in,
in some other scientists have
argued there's two major reasons.
Number one is the impacts of this
disease on members of the deer family
themselves.
And the other is that we cannot rule out
the possibility that CWT could become a
human health issue at some
point down the road. Guys,
you kind of nailed those two with regard
to deer or members of the deer family,
whitetail deer, mule deer, elk, Moose,
and most recently it's picked up in,
in reindeer,
in Norway of all places.
We could articulate some reasons,
some rationale why this disease might
be thought of as being important.
First we'd look at it would be
geographic spread. So you know,
CWD 20 years ago was thought to be this
really novel thing in a very restricted
geographic range and south eastern
Wyoming, adjacent North Eastern Colorado,
and maybe a little spill over and
in Nebraska, a wildlife biologist,
wildlife specialist, and looked at
this disease. It was interesting. Uh,
we didn't know much about
it at that point in time,
but it seemed to be very isolated there.
What does it do to the deer?
A kilter, right? But how
does it kill him? Alright,
so this is a member of a family of
diseases called transmissible spongiform
encephalopathy.
These are [inaudible] so big long words.
Transmissible means it
can go from animal aid.
Animal be spongiform means looks like a
sponge and encephalopathy means disease
of the brain,
she put it together.
And so this disease results in holes
in the brain resulting in progressive
neurological degeneration
followed by death. Okay. It's a,
it's a death sentence and there's no
war for it. It's all you can capture the
deer and give them some sort of metal
cation,
no cure for these diseases.
The sweeter diseases co you know,
there's a,
there's a members of the TSC
group of diseases in humans.
Most familiar is,
is one called [inaudible] disease.
So it's very similar to mad cow
disease in the same family. So,
well I'd take [inaudible] you could say
price, honestly, I would just read it. Um,
that's an interesting,
you know, there's, uh, uh,
goes back and forth on
whether it's pre honor,
prion stand poisoner to receive the
Nobel laureate for his work on these
diseases.
Coined the term to prion.
And in his first publication
describing these diseases,
he did a phonetic spelling and it's prion.
So other researchers,
it's a especially, you know, um,
some from across the pond. Um,
say it's gotta be prion. And
the main reason that, you know,
some of them I've talked to about that
is that an ERC stand poizner when he
hears it called Prion.
Oh, so we'll say Priyanka.
Yeah.
So I'll say [inaudible] from now on.
Now this disease which people
know as mad cow disease, um,
obviously, uh, is transmissible
to humans. And, um,
that's one of the reasons why people are
very scared that this could potentially
jump from deer into humans.
And correct me if I'm wrong,
but it also is making its way into the
actual plants that these animals eat.
You, you're correct on both accounts
show with BSE, mad cow disease,
that was an interesting disease
where it resulted from, in essence,
turning cows into cannibals. We were,
which all cyclists in New Guinea,
right with KCC, Kirksville
with, with crew,
which is a human disease.
A TSC likely started when,
um,
one individual developed Roitfeld
Jacobes disease. That individual died.
And as, as a practice was the practice
in the, for a tribe in Papa New Guinea,
uh,
they practice ritualized cannibalism to
honor the dead and to help release the
spirits from, you know,
deceased family members.
So they would feed upon upon
the corpse and Pour, you know,
the bodies of their deceased.
So when one individual died of probably
have some variant of Coatesville Jakob's
disease, then the causative
agent, the prion protein,
which is concentrated in the central
nervous system and lymphatic systems of,
you know,
of disease patients.
This was fed back to other members of
the family and the extended family.
And so when they got sick and died
veteran again, so we saw that with Kourou,
um, in, uh, in the 19 [inaudible]
1960 [inaudible] around there,
um,
it was realized that this cannibalistic
behavior was likely the result,
you know, or the [inaudible] of
the cause of disease transmission.
Cannibalism was outlawed.
And at that point in time,
you broke completely the d
disease transmission cycle.
So no more new cases of Kourou,
but they had lingering cases with an
extended incubation period up to 40 years
later before Kourou.
Finally burned out of that population.
So now with,
with BSC or mad cow disease,
we were doing exactly in essence the
same thing, not exactly the same thing,
but in essence.
So in an effort to maximize production
and reduce the amount of waste when they
butchered cattle, we would take
all the awful Oh FFA l you know,
the high,
the bones,
the parts that are inedible
and we would had rendered them,
Cook them at high temperature
and typically, you know,
high pressure as well.
And it turns into a slurry
high protein slurry.
You skim the fat off the top of that
and then dehydrate the rest of it.
And you have, you know, kind of a meat
and bone meal, a high protein supplement,
realizing that cattle grow faster
and produce better when they're,
when on a hyper higher protein diet,
it seemed reasonable to use waste
material from cows to feed back to cows.
So at some point, turning, turning,
turning thousand, the candles.
So at some point in time
a cow developed a TSC,
a prion disease,
whether it came from scrapey,
the TSC of sheep or arose
on its own is unknown,
but that cow died.
It was rendered into meat and bone meal
and there's high protein feed was then
fed out to hundreds to thousands. And
correct me if I'm wrong, for these prions,
they can survive up to more than a
thousand degree temperature. Yeah.
Surviving is kind of a, a strange
term, Joe in the, they're not alive.
Start with, it's a protein
a, they can persist,
they cannot be inactivated. So
yeah, it to, he's pretty Harley.
These premiums are not
necessarily a living thing
like a disease or a virus or a
bacteria.
Well there a disease causing agent,
but they are incredibly unique.
They're sitting there and eating Hologic
agent like a virus or bacteria or a
parasite could be causing disease.
But all these other things have
genetic material. They're alive,
which allows them to change
rapidly to evolve over time.
So the whole concept
that you have a protein,
a protein that all mammals produce in
a normal form can be converted after
production into a disease associated
form that has these radically different
characteristics. One that you mentioned
was, you know, resistance to heat,
heat treatment,
a normal prion protein,
and we have billions of them
circulating in our bodies right now. Um,
have a specific purposes,
cellular purpose,
we don't know exactly what it is when
it's likely involved in some sort of
intracellular communication.
It's a string of around 250 amino acids,
so relatively short protein.
It does whatever it's does,
and then the body recycles,
breaks that chain of amino acids down
into its component parts and recycles it.
It turns out that normal cellular
premium protein likely has a half life of
maybe four to six hours. Okay, so you're
producing them relatively constantly.
Then there's the disease associated form
in all diseases associated prions start
as the normal cellular Priya.
So they're converted from one,
three dimensional form to
a different form. Okay.
And this different form has these
radically different characteristics.
One is heat resistance and other
is UV light resistance. Um,
I mentioned that the normal cell prion
protein has a half life of maybe four to
six hours.
The disease associated ones can persist
in the environment for years and
potentially up to decades. Okay.
And when you say persistent,
the environment,
you mean in like on the
ground on leaves on like how,
how would they be
persistence? Yeah, all of those
things jump through. So if a deer,
we'll share [inaudible] infectious agent,
this prion protein.
And so from the time of deer is infected,
it's probably around two
years before it develops.
Clinical signs of disease goes down,
he'll lose as it's fear,
a human's dramatic weight
loss. Um, all of those things,
that incubation period,
it's probably shedding infectious agent
for the vast majority of that time
period. So it looks healthy, but
it's able of transmitting disease.
We'd call that Ala typhoid
Mary Syndrome Syndrome.
The two deer that we,
uh,
that were positive on our farm to box
two and a half year old bucks were we had
them tested. As you know, we're, for the
last several years we've been getting, uh,
initially we got our,
uh,
only bucks tested and then the last
three or four years we've gotten all the
deer tested. They were a two and a
half year old bucks, perfectly look,
perfectly healthy.
And these are the first ones that you've
tested that tested positive and we
tested
in excess of 35 deer over the last,
well more than that, but it would be more
like 50 during the incubation period.
Would they still test positive at
some point? They will at some point.
So that could be spreading
infectious agents testing positive.
Yes. Oh, that's fun.
So it's say it's probably between three
and six months out when we can test an
animal test positive,
but it's likely shedding infectious agent
at least at lower quantities prior to
that point in time.
And so then,
so it's shedding infectious agent.
It's capable of transmitting disease
and cave long before it looks clinically
ill. That's, that's one of the
real challenges with this disease.
From a management standpoint.
They look perfectly healthy,
they act perfectly healthy,
but they're starting to have
that progressive neurological
degeneration that we
can only see very near the end of
disease. So, correct me if I'm wrong,
but this seems like we could potentially
be facing a ticking time bomb of many,
many, many deer that are wandering around
out there right now that look totally
normal, that are spreading this
stuff all over the place and they're,
they're acting normally
look perfectly healthy.
And then obviously with this
multi year incubation period,
this kid just cascade. And I think
we've seen evidence of that now.
Um, started at, you know, he talked
about being isolated disease.
It was picked up in Wisconsin at
the end of 2001. Um, as of today,
CWD has been,
now Penn picked up in 25 states in
captive and or free ranging populations in
whitetail deer, mule deer, elk
or Moose, two Canadian provinces,
uh, in addition to two is
picked up in South Korea.
And that was real interesting.
It was in captive elk and those elk
still had Canadian ear tags in them.
So we pretty much know how CWD those
Elkton swim across the Pacific pond.
Most recently it was picked up,
uh,
two years ago in free
ranging reindeer in Norway.
And subsequent to that,
it was picked up in a small handful,
like three or four moose and a red deer
in Norway in a single moose in Finland.
It's a real concern over in Norway,
um,
with reindeer. Okay. So reindeer
are very gregarious. Yeah.
Whitetail deer, Caribou,
Caribou, reindeer.
So not unusual to see him in herds
of hundreds of animals. So very,
very different than what we see
with whitetail deer, mule deer, elk,
or Moose. We don't see those huge hurts.
But with elk, you can in the wintertime.
But anyway,
it's thought that this gregarious behavior
might really facilitate transmission
and reindeer. Right? So when it was
picked up in reindeer, Norway said,
you know, we maybe should do something.
It's an interesting story. And then, um,
you know, Norway has got experience
with scrapey and sheep, uh,
and so they'd have a long history.
What does scrimping scrapey
is the same as well.
It's the same family diseases in sheep.
It's actually the first one that was
described scrapey we've known since the
early 17 hundreds a disease,
a domestic sheep,
and it's called scrapey because
of the behavior these animals,
once they enter the clinical
phase of disease display and they,
they seem like they itch bat.
And so they'll go up to fence post and
other objects and they literally rub
their hide off of their body.
So that's the name scraping.
And it's the same progressive
neurological disorder followed by death.
And I think about it.
So as this disease creates
vacuums in the brain,
it's killing off neurons.
And so without those neurons firing,
you fall into that
progressive degeneration.
And yet at some point your
body can no longer survive.
And that's what's really spooky about
how this thing kills. So anyway,
go back to Norway when they detected CWT.
Trying to keep this a little bit closer
to you. You're very soft spoken. Oh,
no worries. I can hear myself. Plenty of
the problem is the recording. Sorry. Okay,
no worries.
So when they picked up CWD and reindeer
in Norway and the researchers over there
had witnessed what we are lack of
success on this side of the pond over the
course of the last 20 years. And they
took it very, very seriously. Um,
so they took kind of some harsh medicine.
Uh,
they announced their plans that they
were going to eliminate a herd unit.
They were going to kill every rain
deer in an entire herd unit in Norway.
The idea is to eliminate
the host population.
It's called stamping out
and it works in a pen.
This is the first time had
been done realistically in
a free ranging population.
Oh, ideas. We don't have effective
tools for management. It's disease.
They were very fearful of what would
happen if this spread throughout that
reindeer population and throughout
other reindeer herds. And like Alaska,
they have multiple herds.
Like last year I hunted Caribou with,
with Steve up in the 40 mile river
area. But there were, you know,
and so they're very localized.
This is probably not,
but at least they have a range
that they move through. So,
and in Norway they have two or three
different herds, many more than that.
So I don't know exactly how many heard
points you could isolate one of the herd.
So the idea is before they get to be
any worse before it gets any farther,
let's take it out.
So they had a hunting season.
They allowed a hunter's to
take as many as they could,
which was a little over
a thousand reindeer.
And then they came in
with government agents.
But it's sharp concern that the hunters
could eat something with CWD and then
catch it. Well, that's always a concern.
But what we can talk about human,
let me finish this one up though,
with Norway in it, they took,
literally took the bull by the horns. They
decided to do what was very unpopular.
What we have not been able
to do in North America, they,
and so after the hunting season,
government agent sharpshooters took an
additional 1400 reindeer as they killed
every reindeer in this herd unit.
And they're going to, it fallow,
allow no reindeer in there
for a minimum of five years.
So it says every bit of promise of
being the first large scale success with
dealing with this disease in a free
ranging heard pretty different than what
we've been able to accomplish over here.